[Music]
welcome to viewers Choice Thursday night
6:30 at the same news Chess Club today
we're going to examine a game of mr.
James Kirkland vs. banner link King
I think today's games are much more
instructive than the previous week so
I'm looking forward to this class let's
start with the first game I have two of
them I'm not sure if we're going to be
able to go through both of them but
let's try to do that both of them are
quite long c4 c6 III this is a common
way of confusing your opponent and also
keeping your options open because you're
not committing this pawn all the way to
d4 the structures resemble very much
like a normal Queens gambit declined or
like potentially a Slav if he plays e6 I
mean it transfers into a lot of
potential openings but with a pawn on D
tomb I'm reserving this option of
playing d3 at the right moment and
generally this Bishop on c1 is actually
going to go to B 2 so the positions are
a little bit different the theory is is
non-existent basically there's only
plans rather than precise opening theory
and usually the people as wide that try
to get their opponent out of the theory
land and try to just simply play a game
are going to use this flexible setup
night of 6 d4 I was talking so much and
then he played before
instead of b3 but once again b3 in
general I think I played it a few times
I remember seeing Shanklin from the
American players playing this did this
setup if I'm not mistaken like Murat
right that's all once but
and might be mistaken I know Shanklin
versus Conrad hold they did they had one
or two games in this specific variation
d4 now our simply transposing into an e3
Slav is six now this is the deme or semi
Slav Knight c3 Knight bd7 Queen c2 so
far so good both players are developing
their pieces white is not going to is
going to delay as much as possible the
move Bishop e2 or Bishop d3 because
simply he wants to take on c4 with the
bishop from one move and both players
are going to try to do that to delay
this move D takes c4 at some point this
move will have to be played for example
if white would play something like
Bishop e2 in this position black will
simply just take on c4 Bishop takes c4
and then we're entering a structure that
resembles a little bit that of a Moran
system the bot vinik Bishop e7 Castle
and at some point B 5 B should be 7 and
try to open up the position with c5 if
if we remember we had a very similar
structure in the game of Aronian that we
analyzed last week in the games games to
remember games to know by heart class
against Knight each if you are at home
you can go review it and it will give
you a nice insight into how to how to
approach this type of structures so he
played Queen c2 very normal move very
natural move Bishop to d6 g4 very
interesting move I really like this
approach
well basically white is just trying to
play unconventional chest I've seen it
even at highest level even a camera I
think tried a similar approach if you
take on g4 I'm simply going to go route
Jiwon
and then you're going to have some
problems with the g7 point wherever you
move your night I'm going to take on g7
and then you will find it quite
difficult to get your King to safety I
think taking on h2 should be quite
dangerous though who knows it might be
quite good take take take rook takes g7
I'm also threatening the pond on h7 so I
think that's quite problematic as well
for black and in the same time I'm
having another threat can somebody tell
it to me
for the sake of argument let's just say
black is going to go something like h6
to protect that h7 point what is our
second threat it's a move located when
it's a move the problem is Oh which is
is a part of my candidates as well the
problem is I'm going to have ways to
defend this rook on h8 I can simply just
exchange it if I want to I can also play
a move such as Queen f6 so it's not
necessarily the wise wisest idea to just
start running after that part I think we
have better better alternatives
f-for absolutely we have to always ask
ourselves were what are our our
opponents peace is doing in certain
strange positions like this Bishop on
edge - can we block him can we block his
exit can we capture it right so f4 does
that in the same times in the same time
it attacks him right so everything is
forced he does have one move to defend
it Queen to h4 but now we can continue
with what move another powerful move to
retain the initiative it's a check
so check clean edge for it's a check be
very careful mr. can West I'm giving up
your identity so be very careful what
are the candidate moves
Queen after is one of them or just
simply move in the king away Queen f2 is
a little bit more forced yeah because
we're we're obliging our opponent to
make a decision and after a queen of two
I don't think his decisions are going to
be good well his his options are going
to be good because he can take on f2 but
then we just simply take back and now
the bishop still restrained on h2 and
next move we're going to go either King
actually not King G - I think we're
going to attack it with a rook rook to G
- the route comes back from enemy
territory and then the bishop on h2 is
going to have huge problems yeah he's
not he's bye-bye gone so that's the
second threat that's why I think 90 x h2
and just Knight takes d4 in general it's
quite dangerous
sorry play the move D takes c4 g5 we're
not necessarily going to worry about the
pawn on c4 immediately because we have
other important things to do and that is
just expand on the on the Kings side and
immediately create some sort of
initiative there 95 Bishop takes c4 b5
Bishop to e2 so far so good quite
natural moves Bishop d7 Knight to e4
attacking the bishop on d6 centralizing
the pieces also potentially avoiding the
exchange of the Knights because we have
space advantage and whenever we have
space advantage we don't generally want
to exchange pieces so I think white so
far is doing all the right things Bishop
to e7 h for natural move nevertheless
white also has to be a little bit
careful because if his attack doesn't
succeed then this is going to turn into
what
how do we call when we're moving our
pawns like this aggressively on one side
and then the attack just doesn't succeed
we're going to be over extended and we
definitely don't want to be overextended
in an endgame because if that happens
then black is just going to be able to
start attacking our pawns and our
structure is going to become from a
strength and a pillar of a force to just
a liability yeah so you have to be very
careful keep the pieces on the board try
to continue with powerful moves always
maintain your initiative if you lose
that initiative you're going to be
overextended and structurally you're
going to be worse technically you're
going to be worse
Knight to b6 night c5
I don't like Knight b6 consequence of it
is uh it lives it leaves the c5 square
available for my knight and these two
nights are pretty much stepping on each
other's feet right it's not really doing
much this Knight b6 connecting the
Knights but to be honest connected
Knights are not that good again they
don't have squares for for for each
other so maybe we can find a different
plan here I think black should or should
should try to do something else
something very common actually in this
type of positions what is the most
common thing you have to do in these
structures in these bargaining
structures any ideas
we've seen it actually in in the last
game in the in the Aronian knowledge
from last week we've seen this idea
Black has to do something immediately in
order to kind of survive strategically
at least ask yourself what my worst
pieces are how I can improve them what
am I expected to do from a theoretical
point of view whenever my opponent is
attacking me and is expanding on one
side attack in the center absolutely so
how can we attack the center
will if I help our cause
I don't think so what would help our
cause though would be if we get place c5
this is very typical whenever you see
this structure you're always going to
think about this break either c5 either
a 5v5 a little bit more rare but see if
I very often you're going to see it
unfortunately I think c5 just loses a
pawn yeah probably loses upon probably
loses upon because I can just simply
take and then I think this pawn is also
hanging so we can actually kill two
birds with one stone in this position we
can support c5 and defend the pawn on d5
with the same move and I think that's
Queen b6 yeah absolutely
absolutely no rook c8 is a very typical
move to support c5 as well
Queen b6 rook c8 maybe a six at the
right moment to strengthen the pawn on
d5 but a6 sometimes is loss of temple
yeah you have to be fast in these
positions because if if white oops
if white manages to potentially lock the
Queen side with a 3 B 4 and stop you
from playing c5 then strategically
you're almost lost because of this bad
bishop on b7 my space advantage and so
on yeah I have a lot of trumps in my
hand but if you manage to place c5
suddenly all your pieces are starting to
liven up the bishop on b7 especially and
this is a monster this Bishop on b7 is a
is is one of the best piece Black has at
his disposal so I think instead of
Knight b6 Queen b6 or rook c8 as you
were mentioning Jason what definitely
help blacks cause much more than 96 yeah
96 not so much I don't like it at all
95 Queen c7 also you're giving up the e5
square so you're giving so many so many
squares as black that night on this that
night 27 was very very important
defensive piece
it was defending a lot a lot of squares
efore night to be for all your pieces
are starting to be displaced all of
black's pieces are starting to be
displaced quincy tree also this Queen
nice diagonal ready to attack on the
King night on before you you probably
don't want to go long castle you
probably don't want to go short castle
so we're already going to go you know
suddenly you're in big big trouble
a5 a3 another good move displacing that
powerful Knight forcing him to go to a6
which is the terrible square so white
did indeed play most of the right moves
at the right time timing his timing was
actually quite good night takes b7 okay
that's a move I wouldn't make at first
glance I don't know maybe maybe just
works but to be honest this Bishop is
already locked the knight on c5 is
they're keeping a tight grip on the
position and the bishop on b7 is
basically useless piece if he manages to
get it out sure it's going to be a huge
piece unfortunately that's much easier
said than done
so would you trade such a powerful night
for such a passive piece piece on b7
most of the times not I don't know if it
it makes a lot of sense to do it now to
be honest I would have rather exchange
it for the beach for the knight though I
know I don't want to move I don't want
to displace my night from c5 I just want
to develop my pieces I can either go
Bishop
yeah I have to go Bishop III actually I
do have to go Bishop III and why do I
have to go Bishop III actually I'm not
sure if I have to go mr. p3 okay so the
tactic I was worried about for example
if I go age five this was my other
candidate move instead of Bishop III the
tactic I was worried about was Knight
takes e5 d take c5 and Knight a for
attacking both my Queen and the pawn on
c5 the problem is as I mentioned this
queen is nicely placed to attack the
pawn on g7 and with that being said I'm
not sure how this position suddenly
starts looking like
because whites king is not as safe
either yeah I mean we haven't found
shelter for him yet I'm still pretty
sure I might be wrong but I'm still
pretty sure white should be close to
winning by being greedy and taking
another pot and after we take this pawn
on c5 with the knight defending the pawn
on e6 now we cannot allow allow black to
play a move such as rook f8 and start
getting the initiative start pushing our
pieces back so what we have to do we
have to act immediately and we have to
start pushing his pieces back
immediately with Bishop before the Queen
doesn't really have a good place to to
move in order to defend the bishop on e7
and preserve his initiative if it goes
Queenie Queen d7 I will just simply go
rogue d1 maybe even 95 and I think this
position is uh it's quite good for a
white I would say waiting yeah it's safe
to say it's winning for white because
we're forcing the Queen exchange if we
get the Queen exchanged then I think
that's a pretty nice position black has
a nice little tactic with 93 but I don't
think it works what would you guys play
in this position after 93 quite actually
it's a this might actually work okay at
least to complicate matters what's the
point of 93
correct correct so if you take either
with the bishop either with the rook I'm
going to play Bishop before discovery
check and then you're going to lose your
queen so the only other move that's
available to us is what King to f1
exactly King to f1 and I think this is
the best move in the position and I was
trying to understand what what happens
after a move such as room d f8 or rook h
f8 I think white is good I think white
can just simply play up some like Queen
g7 now you cannot take because you're
losing the other look I think you have
to play here and then I can even
continue taking some points and then at
some point I'm going to be like okay I
don't want equality I'm just going to
move my queen then you take back then I
take on d3 and ok pieces are equal but I
have I think two points up I'm not two
points up and also look at these
monsters look at these monsters ready to
promote yeah so White's activity is just
too much for black in this in this
particular case wait wait wait
we might have missed something guys I
might have me something
what'd I miss I did miss something
that's what that's my last move my last
move was Bishop before this is a mistake
I just realized it very good
93 indeed suddenly I think this is
actually good for black because Bishop
d3 the same idea bishop before it
doesn't matter the queen is the queen is
under attack
King f1 the problem is right now the
queen is on c7 so we have two attackers
on the f4 Bishop yeah we can just simply
grab the bishop now that's going to be a
piece down for us for white so yeah
actually 93 does come quite powerful in
in the game so if I don't have Bishop f4
then suddenly I
I would like to attribute black some
some initiative I think he has some
initiative with good play with very
precise play I think white should hold
this and make use of his extra material
extra pawn with that being said from a
practical point of view this is no easy
task
because black species seem at the moment
quite coordinated that win on f7 I'm I'm
a little bit worried I'm going to lose
it if I don't pay attention of course I
still have a safe route to go back we
had g7 C 3 but if black manages to find
a way to take that away from me then I'm
in trouble
so with that being said that's why I
wouldn't play h5 why I don't want to
give my opponent any sort of counter
play I've been preaching that over and
over again whenever we have a strong
strategic advantage like in this case
there's absolutely no reason to give to
give counter play and for that reason I
would just play Bishop III to defend
extra defend the the knight on c5 and
right now after Knight takes e5 Knight
a4 I can just simply play a move such as
Queen c2
defending the pawn on c5 this night is
quite restrained on the side and I think
white is just waiting okay he took
Knight xb7 inaccurate Queen takes p7
Bishop to f4 castle h5 yeah that's the
castle I don't like this move castle no
actually okay it might be okay you don't
want to castle on the Queen side either
you cannot castle on the Queen side if
you castle on the Queen side suddenly
tactics abound in the position with the
King on c8 and with the absence of the
light square Bishop on b7 who would have
been a good defending piece yeah this
doesn't look good
this or that the pressure on the C value
is just too much so it's either you
castle either you don't create a
connection between the roofs and you
don't necessarily put your king to
safety and you're not going to be able
to place c5 either because the b5 pawn
is hanging so what I want to do is
support the move c5 maybe play before
first and then c5 but I need to get c5
going if I don't get c5 going there's
nothing going for me there is absolutely
no other way to create counter play so I
think for the moment castle is okay my
pawn storm is not as fast and I actually
have a feeling black might be getting
close to to to creating his own counter
play just because of that 90s b7 move
giving the strong night
the staple of our position for the book
for the passive Bishop on b7 okay h5
before looking good so far for black I
like the way he's trying to create some
counter play-doh I would have played c5
directly I want to get my pawns moving
as soon as possible I want to open up
and counter-strike in the center as soon
as possible I think after c5 I don't
know who's better which one it
definitely is but yours is as well
that's the thing c5 injects such such a
dynamic play into my pieces it opens up
everything yeah it opens up the
important diagonals the a8h one diagonal
even with the bishop on b7 still I would
get I would get a lot more activity if
you in this structure c5 is critical and
yeah I'm not really sure who's better
what is for certain is that black is
getting a lot of a lot of counter play
and I think that's more than he could
have hoped for
a few a few moves ago when the night was
still on c5 okay so he played before
still not a bad move as long as it's
followed by c5 I think he should still
be ok black should still be ok
Queen to c2 a 4 mm no why loss of time
this is just a loss of time once again
c5 extremely important play for h6 with
the knight on c5 the character of the
position was much different than without
the knight on c5 it was much more
revolving around strategic play right
now it's all about dynamics it's all
about who's going to get first to the
opponent's king because we don't have
that plug on c5 to stop blacks countably
geez g6
dark squares are ready for whites to
take
hmm
I don't like this move I don't
understand this move this is the type of
very unnecessary exchange where's the
mathematics going
no we're correct nor at least not
anytime soon he needs to find a place
for that night on May 6 he needs to find
a way to activate it and why it was like
ok bring your night into play I'd love
your night to come into play so I'm
going to take on before I'm also going
to create a weakness on b2 absolutely
unnecessary so another misconception and
mistake Bishop takes before no I would
take with the night I would take with
the night because I want to get my
knight into play and I want to keep this
Bishop close to my king I want to have
him ready to defend dark squares which
are the problem in blacks position
mm-hmm
I think so mm-hmm I think so I think
that's a good plan I think we should be
fine maybe which he did actually I think
if if I if I'm not mistaken I think he
did Bishop e5 at some point but once
again it's a matter of a few moves here
a few temples and I do think we should
be find this more precise with that
being said I think black still is fine I
might even go sound like actually no I'm
gonna go c5 I want to try to open up
your position as well as soon as
possible
again white is slowly slowly looking
like it's overextending too much and it
doesn't look like he's going to be able
to make use of his of his advantages
which are the weakness of dark squares
in blacks blacks camp the problem is how
are you going to get to those how are
you going to get with a queen to those
yeah because you would like to checkmate
but that's even more of our extension
and then you push the pawn you go f4 f5
and then what that took three long moves
imagine what black could do in those
three more moves and even if you get
your pawn to f5 you're not gonna do much
no no no you're not cracking anything I
can even take imagine this I'm not
moving anything you move your night away
you play a four a five and then I'm
going to take you cannot take back
because your rook would be hanging right
so does f4 look like look like a good
plan no it does it look like a natural
plan yes it definitely does but
sometimes natural plants are not not the
best ones so yeah I think c5 and if the
computer doesn't say anything which I
don't know if it does or not I think
black is just simply better in this
position he played eight things before
Bishop takes before okay c5 very
interesting finally finally we played c5
a move that I was asking for in the past
and moves Bishop e5 okay like it's still
fine probably better
now see for now this is a move I I don't
like I really don't like support the
level has been quite good but there are
these small little inaccuracies and most
of them are based on on on just wrong
full understanding of the position what
should black do does you want to close
up the put the position on the Queen
side or maybe does he have any other
better options
because ninety seven forty and yes
that's the right answer ninety-seven for
example I'm not really sure what you're
threatening you're taking this night
away from b6 so the pawn on e4 is no
longer protected
that's one consequence how I cannot take
immediate advantage of that is just by
simply taking the pawn and if you take
my my bishop on d5 I can probably take
back with the pawn this Bishop is kind
of out of play on before it's not really
having any active role night on a6
definitely out of play and I could
potentially try to start bringing my
Queen to f6
I managed together I'm going to be
winning long way but still I'm pawn up I
don't have to hurry we have opposite
opposite color bishops I think White has
the initiative White has the better of
Bishop I'm going to play King G to row K
1 and then maybe Quincy one winner for
if but first I have I want to make sure
that your Bishop doesn't get back into
play your Bishop I want him to stay
strained here on b4 blocked by his own
pawn if you want to take it out you
might want to sacrifice the part but
that's a completely different story
yep so 97 to passive I would categorize
it as too passive
either look to see it either look to d8
yeah those are the two moves I'm
definitely eyeing in this position I
want to put my rooks on the central
files and I'm I'm I'm trying to
challenge your pieces position
especially that Queen on c2 that's
another consequence of the C file
getting opened up the fact that your
queen on c2 is slowly slowly starting to
lose its ground so yeah
Brooke I see a truck f d8 and the
position is quite complicated
I don't like c4 it's not a huge blunder
or anything like that nothing immediate
happens but I simply don't see the point
of this movie
c4 I would like those are those central
files to be opened up now I'd like to my
rooks to suddenly have an important role
okay Rock age for defending the pawn on
e4 I like this white is playing at least
with a plan he has a plan he knows what
he wants to do he's defending the e4
pawn first and then at some point he's
going to try to play Quincy one Queen
afore first he has to defend the e4 pawn
rook c8 Quincy one playing with a plan
sometimes even if the plan is wrong
playing with a black explain is better
than not playing with any plan c3b take
c3 and now I think black made a mistake
okay he took on c3 the bishop let's see
if it's a mistake I'm not sure if it's a
mistake or not
Bishop to f4
and now I think Black has only one move
to defend which is what
I think the move he made was not very
good
but I do think he had a better move well
that's a bit too greedy taking the
rookie is a bit too greedy again I I
play Queen f6 I'm threatening Queen a
trade or Queen g7 I think the only way
to defend is probably king of faith but
right now okay what's the most precise
way of ending the game I want the most
precise way I think there might be more
than more than one solution but there is
one that just forces resi the
resignation very quickly in the next
three moves at the most - King to e7
does that force you you're you're a rook
down though that's not the first thing
you should be thinking about no you
cannot think about just grabbing upon
you have to be thinking about what you
have to be thinking about checkmating
the King Bishop to d6 that's a good idea
continue with the first moves black only
has one move after Bishop d6 he can play
King g8 or king a king g8 Queen g7
checkmate yeah so he has to go king e8
not necessary that wins 100% that wins
but he would play rook c6 in that
position and you would have to do oh
actually that wins us that forces a
checkmate as well what I'm firstly
looking at is just trapping this king
the way to trap it is by bringing 925
and now the bishop and the bishop and
the night are controlling both his
escapes course the next move by force is
going to be Queen h8 there is absolutely
nothing stopping me from doing that with
that being said your move Bishop b5 is
also winning on the spot for a different
reason I have to play look to c6 you're
basically cancelling my defender of the
e7 square
you're basically cancelling the screen
on visa because right now after rook c6
I'm simply going to play Bishop takes c6
and then Queen e7 right and if you put
something in front on the seventh rank
like 97 then once again you cancelling
the Queen on b7 and Queen to e7 comes on
the spot so I guess the difference
between the Bishop Bishop b5 and 95 is
just a difference of taste but both of
them are winning completely winning so
taking the rook that's too greedy he
played a move f5 but I don't think
that's the best move I think Midas 7 was
the best move just simply defend the
year 6 square
and there is a saying just that nights
are the best defenders are the best
defenders close to the king so whenever
we were under attack we try to bring our
Knights back bring our Knights closer
the King there are very potent defenders
very very powerful ones so I think 97
Black is doing fine Black is controlling
f6 how are you going together not sure
you have to eliminate somehow the knight
on the night on d7 and that's not going
to be an easy task so I think after 97
Black was doing fine unfortunately for
him he played f5 and now white took the
brave decision but I think accurate of
just giving up the rook Bishop takes a 1
how to continue
force moves 95
supporting f7 Raqqa faith he has to
defend against that
and now I played a very interesting move
I don't know if it's correct I will have
to check it with the engine but I think
from a practical point of view at least
is is quite a nice move forcing his way
through blasting open blacks position
Bishop to h5 another nice move he's
threatening Bishop tastes g 6h takes g6
then h7 then f7 and just check me yeah
he's going for it the guy is ultra
aggressive the guy doesn't believe in
anything just wants to check me the
black king he doesn't believe in
material 94 now if it takes here I think
we can just go Queen g3
and now once again we're starting
threaten f7 and then night xe6 the king
is very very weak yeah I'm not sure how
black defends this might actually be an
accurate sacrifice and here is why
they're doing nothing all of his pieces
all of his pieces are simply doing
nothing he has one defender one pool
rook on f8 that's not doing anything
four pieces coming at you yes yes no I
mean conceptionally white played very
well very well
you know just extremely aggressive but
justified because black's pieces are
were on the other side so night C for
Bishop takes g6 night AC v f7 check yes
hopefully it works hopefully it works it
has to work all right it does work if
you take with the night checkmate in two
moves Bishop takes h7 and Queen f6
checkmate so he's forced to take with
the rook let's see how he continued ok
Knight takes f7
[Music]
I'm thinking night of six or queen of
six sorry Knight takes c6 not Knight f6
there's no such thing as Knight f6 okay
let's see how he played I think 96 works
as one 1960 with the idea to play rook
g4 and and checkmate him like that but
let's see what he calculated okay you
are going to take my queen
that's almost almost a given but I'm not
sure if black is going to have enough
counter play after that or not let's see
so the question is why didn't he play
the King f8 I think this was the
critical line we have to continue with
Queen d6 with the track now if he goes
King g7
actually the not sure where GA it works
I think because you're threatening to
checkmate me here on g7 I have defense
of playing Bishop takes d4 but then
right now I think you can just capture
this pawn on e6 and now create a double
attack and then that's it yeah yeah
because your your your king is extremely
extremely unsafe from material point of
view black is doing perfectly fine three
pieces for the Queen
but when you have this type of material
material imbalances especially against
the Queen if the Queen has targets and
if the King is weak then the Queen is
most most of the time is going to be a
superior coordinate coordination whether
that means coordinated for the attack or
coordinated for the defense
unfortunately in this position your
pieces are not coordinated for anything
and your King is extremely extremely
weak so my queen has a lot of targets
let's see what he did
Queen to g6 rook takes two six and the
same story
Queen for three pieces but my queen is
just a monster I wouldn't have allowed
that but this one is also because of
Queen b6 I would assume yeah I think he
gave him a bit too many chances
he should have finished him a little bit
easier but this is winning as well of
course though you always have to be
afraid of blockades you know when you
only have a queen if you lose the pawn
on e4 you will have to worry about
blockades the problem is I don't think
he's going to be able to give that
bishop away for for the point that point
is basically more valuable than your
Bishop on f2 and white understood that
and he made very good use of it Queen to
d7 well actually he resigned after rook
f8 probably he played a move he resigned
because Queen d7 comes on the board King
f6 white pushes the pawn and that's it
game over I'm going to promote then he's
going to be a queen for the bishop and
just a winning position so I'm quite
impressed I'm quite impressed with this
with this attack by white he sacrificed
absolutely everything once he started
sacrificing he never looked back you
know if you do look back and if you stop
playing powerful movies if you stop
playing you know move such as Bishop h5
to try to completely shatter black
structure on the King side then you're
just going to be a rock down so you have
to you know go for broke goal in and he
did why did that and he got repaid so
congratulations to james kirkland in his
victory against what's-his-name Benelli
King
[Music]